okay rusty what's next okay well we've
got a woman named nikki jabs who went
viral on tick tock buzzfeed reports
nikki's date sent her home in an uber
because he was embarrassed of her outfit
oh you could see it here apparently he
felt she she looks cute i will say in
this little pink coat and pink pants
well he thought she was too overdressed
for his work event as an athleisure
company so he just dialed up an uber and
sent her home and then she broke up with
him but she's like sobbing in the back
of the cab because it's so
rude to do to somebody
this woman is literally
sobbing with tears in the back of a car
because this guy made her feel so bad
about
like
what is his problem i have no idea and i
have to tell you like if you're dating
somebody who makes you feel that way um
i hope to mourn the relationship you
wear sequins honey that's what i hope
you wear because this is unacceptable
i mean
i'm
this thought this disappoints me i'm not
going to lie but you know what i love i
love that she ended the relationship
that she stood up for herself so many
times have you ever done this where you
just if somebody says i don't like this
about you you try to change it to make
them happy do you do you well i think he
actually did her an incredible favor
because he showed his cards right away
on what a toxic human being that he is
um it's disappointing but i'm glad he
quickly and swiftly
did this so that she never has to you
know
deal with a guy like this again and i
bet coming out of this she'll get a huge
response because this is everywhere
right now
so something good will come out of this
for her i agree i hope so too
i'm glad he showed her who he was
and
this guy
you know
i'd like to
tell him a few things
i'd like to watch you do that oh i just
want to
eviscerate him i really do he's lucky to
have a date
loser um i'm sorry did i say that out
loud yep you did we all heard it yeah
i'm sorry
just you know it's not even i wish he's
not a loser he's cruel i don't
understand cruel people no he's a loser
because he lost her sorry i'm sorry yeah
all right and finally it's time for a
pic from drew's little yellow book that
is our stuff
that i personally curate for you because
i want you to know about it it's on our
website we refresh it every week i take
this thing very seriously okay i am
totally obsessed with i know i'm really
late to this party but i don't care
yellowstone i am loving this show
so much it's like if you like succession
you're gonna love yellowstone and if
you're not like really big into like
snappy new yorky stuff but you love like
family high stakes like you know big
powerhouse kind of themes like it's just
so rich
i love it
everybody's talking about this this show
and it's been out for a couple years
right but having this major moment i i
can't recommend it enough more it is
just great great great television and i
see what all the fuss is about and now
that there's four seasons out you can
just bend yourself to heaven so okay
actually oh my gosh we have a clip from
the show take a look the new chief is
hungry for a fight
i'm gonna buy your ranch
and i'm gonna pull down every fence
it looked like it used to when it was
ours
just tell me how to fight
everyone
all right you know what
you convinced me to watch bridgerton you
convinced me to watch emily in paris and
now i'm going to watch this show because
you recommend it well and if you go on
our website we did a theme week and it's
literally our entire watch list and
there are so
many good picks it's very diverse
it's very genred and it is just i
research watch lists all the time
because i love binging tv and i'm always
looking our watch list is like really
good so check it out i trust your tv
palette you get so much information that
it's like you forget wait what was that
thing i wanted to watch
go to our list on the drewberrymore
show.com the drew's little yellow book
we got your back
[Music]
you